goodies and Brian as you mentioned
downtown Las Vegas one of the many areas
seeing a startling spike in that number
of stolen cars now I spoke with one
woman tonight who had her car taken
right from in front of her home
it was stolen in the morning I believe
what started as a normal day last week
quickly took a turn Diamond who doesn't
want to share her last name details the
moment she went outside Friday morning
to realize someone stole her car right
from her Summerlin apartment complex
that's why I was just telling my mother
like I just I'm still in uh shock right
now she filed a police report and is
hoping to get it back but until then
she's stuck waiting diamond is just one
of many who's had this same thing happen
more than 10 000 cars were stolen in
Metro's jurisdiction last year
467 have already been taken just weeks
into the new year that's a 40 jump from
this time in 2022. Diamond says more
than anything she feels violated of
course I want my car back but there's
things inside that um I can't replace so
yeah that's what I want back more than
anything and while Metro Police say they
do recover about 75 percent of stolen
vehicles within a week whatever was
inside is tougher to track down that's
why Diamond encourages others to be
aware and take every precaution possible
it makes sense like I kind of figured
it'll happen
[Music]
now another thing to note a lot of times
thieves will switch out license plates
on a stolen car so it's important to
remember other identifying marks on your
vehicle for police also a good thing to
do is check to see if you have
comprehensive coverage on your insurance
which covers auto theft rather than just
liability reporting live tonight Sasha
Loftus 8 News Now